pour aider l'ukraine à se défendre face
à l'envahisseur russe joe biden sort les
grands moyens le président américain a
demandé ce jeudi au congrès une aide
supplémentaire de 33 milliards de
dollars soit 31 milliards 400 millions
d'euros
le coût de cette guerre est élevé mais
céder à cette agression serait plus
coûteux si nous laissons faire
soit nous soutenons les ukrainiens
qu'ils défendent leur pays
soit nous restons à l'écart tandis que
les russes continuent leurs agressions
et leurs atrocités en ukraine cette
nouvelle enveloppe comprendrait plus de
19 milliards d'euros d'assistance
militaire 8 milliards d'euros d' aide
économique et 3 milliards d' aide
humanitaire et alimentaire des sommes
colossales qui permettent aux états unis
de s'affirmer davantage comme les
premiers soutiens de kiev depuis le
début de l'invasion russe washington a
déjà fourni plus de 7 milliards 600
millions d'euros d' aide à l'ukraine la
france arrive en cinquième position des
plus gros contributeur avec 416 millions
d'euros le soutien européen total des
états membres et des institutions de
l'union européenne s'élève pour sa part
à 6 milliards 900 millions d'euros les
etats unis se préparent aussi à une
guerre longue en ukraine avec cette
nouvelle rallonge budgétaire la maison
blanche cherche à obtenir assez de
financements pour soutenir l'effort de
guerre ukrainien jusqu'à octobre mais le
projet de loi pourrait buter au congrès
sur les désaccords entre démocrates et
républicains les démocrates souhaitent y
inclure une hausse du budget destiné à
la lutte contre le comique 19 une mesure
que les républicains refusent